hey everyone and this week's episode
we'll talk about the most popular and
commonly used programming language
Python so let's begin and learn about
the development of fighting and gain
insight about the current IT trends but
before that make sure to subscribe to
our channel and hit the by lighting to
get notified every time to come up with
new content python is very famous for
its simple programming syntax core
readability and English like commands
that make coding a lot easier and
efficient due to this it is the most
popular and preferred language Python is
interpreted high-level general-purpose
programming language developed by Guido
van Rossum at National Research
Institute for mathematics and computer
science Netherlands in contrast to
popular belief that Python was named
after the sleek feyten was actually
named after the show Monty Python's
Flying Circus guido van rossum
formulated faisal in the late 1980s as a
successor to the ABC language in 1994
python version 1.0 was released with
features like exception handling lambda
map filter and reduce Python 2.0 release
in 2000 introduced features like list
comprehensions and a garbage collection
system capable of collecting reference
cycles
Python 3.0 was released on the 3rd of
December 2008 undoubtedly both in 2.0
and 3.0 have proven to be the most used
versions as today Python three point
seven point four is the latest stable
version released in the summer of 2019
Python is popularly used for development
scripting and software testing top IT
companies like Google Facebook Instagram
Spotify and Netflix among others you
spiteful some major applications of
Python can be seen in the fields of
machine learning artificial intelligence
data science and IOT button also offer
many libraries like numpy side by Cara's
tensorflow Django and flower
Bathgate is the official style guide
that defines the styling conventions -
code a few popular open-source Python
projects include red env chata sticks
solving the Traveling Salesman problem
using self-organizing maps and packed
into BPF converter some of the trending
fights and repositories on github today
include ni p and melt from scratch by
touch
transformers 100 days of ML code among
others popular websites on the internet
like Reddit and kora a page using Python
civilization for battlefield 2 Sims 4
and World of Tanks are some popular
games developed using Python according
to indeed the average salary of a Python
developer in India is about 5 lakhs per
annum and that in the u.s. is around 124
thousand US dollars users and admirers
of Python especially those considered
knowledgeable are referred to as
spiciness party nice tasks and patch
minions since its inception Python has
come a long way to become the most
popular coding language and continues to
revolutionize by the industry so that is
all for this episode of like and share
the video if you find this interesting
we will be back with another technology
in the next episode until then keep
learning and stage recently lon
[Music]